so we've seen crowdfunding just explode
since we launched our Kickstarter
campaign in 2010
well your first Kickstarter campaign and
I believe we found one of our interns
the horses busy googling that
Kickstarter announced over what is it
100 million dollars rajd prior to
independent films since their inception
so we believe that it's gotten a lot for
it to succeed what do you think is going
to be the magic trick to get people to
you know get beyond the initial family
and friends or is it matter of building
an audience and taking them along with
you yeah i think it's a it's a cross
it's definitely you know no matter when
you do one it's obviously going to be
family and friends first and if they've
been already tapped once then yeah they
might not be able to do it again and
that's when you rely on the new wave of
fans ideally or maybe you have a new
baby brother that you can have a new
family member sprouts up you can ask
them for money I you know I I've been
lucky enough that films that I've done
have generated kind of interest and fans
from people thank God you know and so
every film or future project I have
people writing me already saying well if
you're gonna do another crowdfunding 1
i'm gonna give you money and stuff but i
don't take that to the bank because you
know with the economy and and with all
the other campaigns out there it's
really tough to navigate in
differentiate yourself unless you have
some type of hook nowadays or a really
huge fan base like I feel I don't feel I
have enough of that type of you know
thing to get a significant amount of
you know I think Kevin Smith or
Soderbergh easily the crowdfunded
million-dollar film anyway I think we've
seen charlie kaufman do his like some
animated film or something so there's
you know there's there's something there
to it and I just said wonder you know
how at our level how it can how it can
sustain itself because i'm not sure it'd
be a good experiment to see you know
someone who's done it like a Gregory
bein like you know some someone who's
done it a few times to see how they
could then go back I don't know who
wants to be the guinea pig Gregory maybe
I don't know I don't know someone to be
the guinea pig to go back and the thing
is like I think anyone any one of us
could do to 3,000 4,000 5,000 as if
you're trying to do like 15 20 30
thousand but you've done a few campaigns
like that then I think it's up it'll be
interesting I'm not sure if the answer
is but will be interesting do you see
that too many people get ambitious they
see people
they don't have the audience
yeah I think a lot of them you know
there's a lot of smart ones that do
their homework and realize this is where
my audience is and this is the hook and
this is the goal I should set and I'm
going to I'm going to make a great pitch
video and have things going and then
there's the people that are kind of
probably very passionate but there's a
streamer so they see somebody else's and
think okay because they did 50 you know
it must be pretty easy if I have like a
cool little you know campaign going is
something they realize how hard it is
when you know we just got on got on
Twitter last week to talk about it or
something so you know it's something
where it's it's it's I think it's going
to be around which is great I just think
people are going to have to start using
it differently and there's no right or
wrong answer because everyone has their
own special case for what their project
is and it just depends on what that
project is what where you can tap into
with it
ten years from now
yeah I do I mean it might be in a
different way a different model you know
I might make Kickstarter may or may not
be around anymore crowdfunding might be
considered a different thing but I still
feel kind of like that's the wave of the
future is how kicks orders said like I
think there may be the biggest
independent film production company in a
sense you know and I think that's
something something like that in the
future just you know still pulling
resources in whatever way is still going
to be them the way to get films done
you